[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
on avait joué mon émission on va
comparer les réponses avec la la fois
d'avant écrit tu me fais penser à
monsieur de fursac moi je te jure être
l'homme le jeu s'appuie le musée
deviendra vraiment monsieur chirac à
prendre
avoir un chien 10h05
non jamais vue du jour j avais je
préviens la chaîne que je ne suis pas
sûr d'arriver au bout de cette émission
et c'est la première fois que je ressens
ça car je vais pas y arriver mais son
petit petit matin heureusement schneider
non ils sont depuis son rôle est alors
qu'il a fallu à ses invités mal qu'il a
fait aux gens ils adorent cela
excusez moi excusez moi non
bonjour par le corps et des bons rêves
celui je vous demandais il ya dix ans
qu'elle est à l'époque tutoyait les gens
me demandaient la bise à tutoie pas moi
je vous disais qu'est les insultes qui
t'a fait le plus mal tu es mon ami a
répondu quoi servent du prix coûte
modalités et fait quelque chose tandis
qu'il a dit ramzy
voilà
le retour de ranger
bon donc il ya dix ans je demandais à
sophie duez quelle est l'insulté qui t'a
fait le plus mal si vous posez la
question aujourd'hui vous répondriez
quoi voir si c'est la même
je crois que c'était frappadingue non
ribouldingue nom de grosse vache non
vous n'êtes pas loin
grosse truie nombreuses vaches mères est
tentant oui oui je vois ce qu'ils
assurent questions sur mon petit boudin
non il ya grosso va bien gros de dans un
gros boudin non c'était gros tas non non
vous ne puissiez pas ce que j'avais
quinze centimètres de moi avec les
autres j'étais un peu ronde alors quand
je vous disais qu'est ce que tu as à
l'époque tutoyait qu'est ce que tu as de
plus sexy en toi et vous me répondiez
non vous avez répondu les sourcils à
l'époque de social qu'est ce qui vous
est le plus indispensable pour vous
endormir
c'est pas très sexy des sourcils enfin
moi je sais ce qu'elle disait à l'époque
figure toi que
lorsque tu vois à quel point ça fait
peur à beaucoup d'hommes a beaucoup de
metteurs en scène les sourcils
ah oui on m'a demandé ma foi des piles
et mes sourcils quoi bon sens des poils
et que ça fait peur donc je suis sûr
qu'il ya un vote
j'en avais juste colère mène à des
pompages été à l'école ce qui m'a sauvé
c'est brooke shield qui est arrivé qu'a
lancé la mode des grands jours si jamais
le plus indispensable avant de vous
endormir
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui bon petit coup
de nom d amorce d amorçage maintenant on
attend déjà les désamorcer d'aller
respirer l'élégance endormi de mes deux
petites filles ont couché mais voilà à
l'époque c'était manu way et bal à la
suite effet voilà la suite maintenant
c'est les enfants à la chance le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte un plateau de
télé à l'époque vous aviez répondu les
bras je suis très brave or aviez dit
c'est d'essayer d'expliquer comment tuer
bras je te pose est comment les bras les
bras c'est ça alors si tu veux entre
entre les bras là il ya une place moi
j'ai pas le temps
voilà c'est une émotion tu m'as fait
très vite pensé que j'étais panne et la
bonne génération alors là c'était toute
une heure ce film sophie duez est une
femme du xviiie siècle sérieux pas le
savoir 18e à paris alors à l'époque j'ai
demandé à sophie duez à quoi reconnait
tue la passion qui s'éteint et vous me
répondriez aujourd'hui je vais vous dire
vous vous disiez à l'époque on fait plus
l'amour
ouais moi toute façon je pense que quand
il ya plus assez de temps je pense que
non mais franchement gênant parce que au
départ je me disais si un homme veut
coucher avec une fille c'est qu'ils
aiment pas ils étaient intéressés que
par que par que moi là le dire que par
ça mais en fait j'ai compris en vivant
qu au contraire c
ces preuves que le couple peut exister
si elle ce désir là il faut pas en avoir
peur
dans le conflit télépathe et une jeune
fille ont 40 et duke un peu comme ça on
te dit temps si l'homme items il en
affiche de ça c'est pas vrai c'est ça
c'est qu'il ya un problème
voilà moi j'ai moi personnellement j'ai
jamais fait l'amour mais en tout cas je
sais que quand ça je les fais cette fois
je jouais j'attends la bonne foi j'ai la
bonne personne mais j'attends encore
mais il est très gentil
c'est jean michel jean michel2 elle eu
une fille à l'époque je demandais à
grands pas eric et ramzy mais à vous est
ce que vous préférez vous est ce que tu
préfères te faire voir quelques
préféreriez de faire te faire draguer ou
est dragué et vous me disiez à l'époque
pas si vous verriez la même chose
aujourd'hui les hommes qui m'attire ne
drague pas donc j'ai obligé de faire le
premier pas moi j'ai une phrase pour ça
c'est tout ce qui me prennent la tête je
les jette
excusez-nous sophie mais je préfère le
climat qui a maintenant en tout cas
j'aime bien ton prénom me rappelle quand
même un canal famille vera panama canal
de dieu on a dû la fermer
les montagnes mais montano mais j'aime
aussi aller montagne c'est vrai les
montagnes où on va rallumer la lumière
la passe et e tron un bac de l'acte
[Applaudissements]
mais savoir pourquoi on applaudit là on
applaudit des sports à l'humain
n'importe quoi therrien avait du monde
et manipule ça fait 20 ans tu fais de la
télé pourquoi tu applaudis mais les airs
mais quand on rallume la lumière c'est
la fin d'une séquence on a plus chez toi
chez lipp ces rituels c'est un rituel
des talibans dans ce rituel ces petits
riens échangés ont échoué l'an 2010
renault la télé en main comment on
repart sur des tableaux comme anne
hathaway et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu